hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bow man 2 now I apologize
for the videos being late today last
night I had sort of a health thing
happen it I'm not gonna go into details
but it's nothing life-threatening I
didn't need to go to the hospital or
anything but it took me out of
commission for a few hours so I couldn't
record last night and I have to record
today that's why it's late I'm totally a
hundred percent okay nobody panic I'm
just explaining why the videos are late
today but this is Bo man and I love Bo
man because when I was in college
instead of studying and working hard at
the college courses I was at I was in a
computer lab and I would always play
this game it got so bad that one time my
professor actually came up behind me he
snuck up on me he's a sneaky old man he
just came up behind me and creeped up on
me but he asked me what the hell I was
doing and so I just ended up explaining
the game to him while everyone else in
the class was looking at me and it was
super awkward but then he said he tried
to became for himself and he enjoyed it
so I think you'll enjoy it too so the
basic premise is that you are a bo man
and I've added wind you can add two
different features you can add wind in a
wall and that may not make a lot of
sense to you but basically you're trying
to fire this bow and you can calculate
your angle and your power one of the
easier ways to do it is just max out a
hundred percent power and then go by the
angle so if I know where this guy is
yeah but the distance whoa I was I was
not looking at the angle I was just
trying to explain
oh my foot you [ __ ] it goes like 14 so
4180
okay well he dead oh [ __ ] I didn't even
know that basically the distance between
you and the computer they randomly
generate so it's it's different
depending on what game you play it'll go
like I got lucky that round I got super
lucky I'm pretty sure it's not gonna be
the same place again okay yeah so he
changes position and one of the reasons
it's easy to do just 100% because it it
removes a factor that you have to
calculate for all right in the neck I'm
not paying attention to the numbers I'm
trying to actually talk to you guys but
if you hit him a few times right through
his body
how's that alrighty then let's try that
once more through your heart okay so you
hit him and you can either get a head
shot or go right through the heart and
you'll win and you know you win because
spouts of blood start shooting out of
there or you can do what I tried to do
sometimes and just try to get as many
arrows into his testicles as possible
before the game ends and to do that you
got to aim a bit lower than usual come
on bro
oh yeah ain't never gonna get me see the
wind adds a little bit extra because
whoo [ __ ] because for me it just means
that you can't wow that's close to my
head it just means that you can't go off
of what the computer does always Oh
little lower I just need to go a little
lower to get to the balls and hopefully
he won't turn me into a pin cushion
before I turn his testicles into I
didn't cushion oh man I thought that was
higher I keep going right through the
heart I'm too good at this yeah they're
like the other thing to do like the
hundred strategy is actually kind of
it's kind of [ __ ] because it removes
a factor and it's almost always the same
but I just want to get I want to get low
he's really close this time I just want
to get arrows into his testicle okay
that was my face thank you very much Oh
your knee you took Skyrim to the knee oh
my knee you son of a [ __ ] I'm gonna
blast you right in the balls there we go
that was the stuff all right you you
prepare because you're in for a world of
hurt I got this locked in at five point
what was it there we go five point five
so I don't know if I can win I can't
remember if I could win if I get enough
into his ball oh right in the grundle
area let's see I think I think if you
get four right yep if you give four
he'll bleed profusely from his groin
area until he dies so anyway that's that
uh and there's another there's another
way to play if you go into the settings
you can add wind or a wall and the wall
is a bit more interesting when you play
because you're not just doing it at a
hundred
you got to get over whoops you got to
get over this wall which randomly
generates its height and I don't know if
the computer can compensate for that I
forget if it can usually you can play
this against other people but it doesn't
have any online functionality so you got
a guy just you know do your thing and
now I'm overshooting 2x4 yeah I don't
even wait for my arrow to get done
thanks buddy
okay so you got a okay so now you got to
calculate the angle and the power so 60
by 45 is not enough I'll keep it at 60
degrees because that's probably a good
angle so 60 by it before
boink okay 65-58 would probably be good
enough Oh
one by one but he got a shot off so we
both died okay anyway so there's only
one other game mode in this and I highly
recommend playing this it's totally free
game it's back in the days of free flash
but there's there's bird hunting mode
which is oops
first off with a Miss well second off
with the Miss oh [ __ ] he's getting away
that easy
point point got to redeem my title as I
don't know what but some some some whoa
[ __ ] how did I kill myself why is our
bird attached to my head oh god I'm just
getting bird trap it's boink
oh [ __ ] boink well what you can do is
you can spear two in a row it's got a
rare but I can do it there we go two in
a row so basically it's a time waster
but it's a very good time waster and I
love time wasting because you screw
actually doing work who needs to but
either way that is Bo man I highly
recommend trying it for yourself
it's a lot of fun I mean what's the harm
check the link in the description below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and I'll get the second video out pretty
soon I'm gonna actually be playing
probably the outlast 2 demo because I
finally got my hands up but we'll see
what happens
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video spices perfect exactly
what I need